نرغب بان تسدل هذه الحرب
وتضع اوزارها باسرع ما يمكن
والرساله الى روسيا هي رساله واضحه
هي عباره عن الوحده التي حققناها فيما
بيننا فاننا ندعم اوكرانيا
والمواطنين في اوكرانيا فلديهم الحق بان
يتمتعوا بحياه سلميه
فهم الذين
سعوا فقط الى بلوغ سلم عادل
هذا ما شددنا عليه في اجتماعنا اليوم وهذا
ما سوف نستمر في قوله
الى الشعب الاوكراني السؤال الاخر
اود ان اطرح هذا سؤال على الرئيس زلنسكي
وعلى رئيس وزراء الدنمارك هل ناقشتهم اي
تفاصيل
ترتبط بالدعم المادي من قبل دول شمال
اوروبا
قبيله انعقادي قمه مجلس المجلس الاوروبي
الرئيسيه
الان
نعم لقد تحدثنا عن استمرار الدعم من قبل
كافه دول اوروبا الشماليه وليس فقط
الدعم الدفاعي بل دعم اقتصادي من اجل
اعاده البناء فاجزاء كبيره من هذه البلاد
فائزه
الان بزياده حجم دعمها الى اوكرانيا ولقد
تحدثنا كثيرا حول
القمه المقبله للمجلس الاوروبي لان
اوكرانيا سوف تكون هي محطه تركيز ليس فقط
حول المسائله بل ايضا حول كيفيه احلال
العدل هناك
وسوف يستخدم جزءا من هذا الاجتماع للتركيز
على بعض القضايا المحدده ولا سيما بالنسبه
لمعادله السلام التي قدمها الرئيسكي فضلا
عن استثباب واحلالي العدل
ومشكله المسائله وهناك ايضا واحده من
النقاط الاخرى ضمن النقاط العشر المتعلقه
بالنواحي الاقتصاديه
في ظل الدمار قلبي الكبير الذي تعرضت له
اوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا
اود ان اخبر دول اوروبا الشماليه باننا
ممتنون للغايه على دعمكم
السخي في ميدان المعركه وعلى ما تلقيناه
من شركائنا
وانني ممتن لكافه دول اوروبا الشماليه عن
تعبيرهم على الوحده والتضامن مع اوكرانيا
في بعض المسائل المحدده بعينها وليست فقط
في المجال العسكري واني اتطلع الى هذه
القمه المقبله
المزمع عقدها
وعلما بانني اتيت الى هنا لاعبر صراحه
باننا لابد لنا ان نعبر عن امتناننا
الكبير لدعمكم اللا محدود منذ اندلاعي
الحرب من يوم منذ يومها الاول واودو نشكر
القيادات
الاوروبيه
على حجم الدعم الذي شهدناه منكم سواء في
ميدان المعركه او في التامين القوى
الدفاعيه المطلوبه وعليه اود ان اشكر كافه
الدول
والدول التي سوف تكون حاضره في القمه
المقبله شكرا لشركائنا
سؤال الى الرئيس والى
وزير الخارجيه ادى المركزي
البعض يتساءل بانه لماذا يتوجب علينا ان
نثبت قدراتنا في ميدان المعركه قبل
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا قبل حصولها على المعدات
العسكريه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات